hey nice to meet you guys good to see
you
as well
i this was so exciting as a fan to watch
and i can't imagine as a fan but also
someone who is excited to film this it
must have been so exciting for you to
see as well what was it like for both of
you to actually see the finished product
up on the screen
camille
um
it was really really overwhelming you're
in a room with hundreds of people you
know this is something we shot we
finished up last year so
i honestly was very very very very
nervous watching it with so many people
i'd seen the movie before but it was
just me and selma in the theater alone
and now you know it's hundreds hundreds
of people watching it still kind of
processing it but it was awesome to see
you know all the other
uh people that i got to work with in the
reactions the crowd had to their
characters
lauren you guys have
such great chemistry on screen together
um it must have been such a blast to
film how much fun was it to do
oh it was a blast it was a blast i had a
great time
um and it wasn't all fun and games even
though there were some challenging
moments
i do i remember there was this windy
sandy scene
it was on the cliff that huge money shot
that you guys saw um where like all the
eternals they like all come together
they're standing on the cliff that was
hell
but you wouldn't know it
and you play the first deaf superhero in
the mcu which is phenomenal what does
this moment mean
this moment for me
uh means that my sons who are both deaf
um
they are growing up in a world where now
they can be deaf superheroes and that's
a big deal and it's kind of like next
you know that's what i want that's what
i want for them
that's beautiful um camille
something that we love about kingo is
that he is actually a movie star
in the movie so which mcu character do
you think is actually the biggest fan of
kingo's hollywood movies
wow that's a very good question i don't
think it's any of the eternals i mean
makari hasn't even seen any of his
movies
[Laughter]
um
that's a very good question you know i
feel like uh bruce banner
is like he's like a worldly guy he's
checked out some of his movies i think
he's a fan
is there a chance and i know that
with the bollywood scene with the
dancing that was something that you had
to like i guess get pumped up to do
right
but is there a chance that we could see
one of kingo's movies actually
happen like in real life could we get
one of his actual movies to go watch i
mean how fun would it be to do a real
shadow warrior movie i mean wouldn't
that be a great disney plus show i don't
know who's who's on this zoom right now
but maybe they're taking notes
i love it i'm i'm all for it if there's
a petition i'm signing it 100
thank you
thank you so much guys pleasure to meet
you all the best nice meeting you
you